Попри те, що Франк-Вальтер Штайнмаєр – перший президент Німеччини
який з 2010 року відвідує Росію
великого політичного значення цій поїздці не надають
Адже головний привід робочого візиту
передача кафедрального собору апостолів Петра і Павла у Москві
Євангелістично-лютеранській церкві
*співають у церкві*
Лютерани - релігійна меншина в Росії
Більшість у громаді має німецьке коріння
Їхні предки приїхали в Росію століття тому
на запрошення царів, які обіцяли землю та релігійну свободу
Але пізніше радянський уряд переслідував лютеран
і захопив церковне майно, включно з цим собором
Громада, яку очолює архієпископ Дітріх Брауер
використовує приміщення собору після розпаду Радянського Союзу
Однак всі ці роки собор
залишався у власності уряду Росії
Хтось зайняв цю квартиру і вона стала вже не твоєю
Ти там, тобі дозволяють з’являтися і щось проводити
Однак весь час є відчуття, що це не твоє.
У будь-який момент це може знову опинитися або у руках держави
або якихось третіх осіб
А зараз це знову повноцінно наш власний дім.
В атеїстичному Радянському Союзі
багато церков використовували не за призначенням
З 1937 року цей собор був кінотеатром і кіностудією
Тоді всі лютеранські церкви закрили
а багато їхніх пасторів заарештували або розстріляли.
Тут на Введенському цвинтарі у Москві
давно відомому як німецьке кладовище
досі відчутні наслідки переслідувань
Багато надгробків були спаплюжені або знищені
Після Другої світової війни лютеранська громада
боролася з тавром німецького походження
яке часто пов'язували у СРСР з нацистським ворогом
Частково ця подія є встановленням історичної справедливості, історичної правди
Однак лише частково
Я дуже сподіваюся на те
що це буде лише початком нового етапу
розвитку і нашої країни, і нашої церкви
Це не перший випадок, коли церкву повертають релігійній спільноті
Однак передача кафедрального собору Петра і Павла має важливе символічне значення
Тепер, за словами архієпископа Брауера
всі громади "дивляться на Москву"
і сподіваються, що вона поверне й інші церкви людям